okay so Ryan Gosling just put out a statement
addressing the fact that he got a nomination in Barbie did it
when I tell you that
like I knew that Ryan Gosling was going to do this and I'm
like emotional
so in a statement
he says that while he's honoured to be nominated
there is no Ken without Barbie
and there is no Barbie without Greta Gerwick and Margot Robbie
so what he's doing here is acknowledging the female labour
that is rendered invisible
but that was necessary for him to even be nominated for an Oscar today
and the reason why this makes me emotional
is that it is so rare for men to acknowledge the female labour that is required
for them to receive the accolades and the praise
that they disproportionately receive as men in a patriarchal world
this is a man who
more than a decade ago
who called out Hollywood for giving an R rating to Blue Valentine
his movie with Michelle Williams
because she was receiving oral segggs in the scene
this man is my Roman Empire